salut la team menthe à l'eau ça y est
c'est la reprise durant environ un mois
je vous ai mis des énigmes et sur la
chaîne youtube vous y avez répondu bras
vote ce qu'on trouve des énigmes bravo à
ceux qui ont résisté à la tentation de
donner la réponse dans les commentaires
il reste encore quatre mois à tenir pour
réussir le défi du mental bloc qui est
je vous le rappelle faire une vidéo par
jour pendant un an depuis le 1er janvier
où j'ai lancé tout ça jusqu'au 31
décembre qui se rapproche dans cette
vidéo je vous donne toutes les
nouveautés qui veillera sur la chaîne
les petits changements bestiaux nice je
vous parle aussi de 2017 et de quelques
surprises
donc tu es obligé de rester jusqu'à la
fin premier changement il y aura plus de
calendrier sur la chaîne alors le
calendrier il est quand même simple
c'est une vidéo tous les jours à 17
heures la semaine et à 11 heures le week
end mais jusqu'ici je donnais un thème
au jour de la semaine les lundis c'était
plutôt le blog le mardi je mentalise est
quelqu'un le problème c'est qu'en y
réfléchissant cet été j'ai trouvé que ça
me brider alors je garde tout les mêmes
concepts mentalité des gens vous faire
du blog vous donner des astuces de
mentalisme ferme des master class faire
des explications de mentalisme mais il y
aura pas de jour défini ce sera aussi en
fonction de ce que j'ai de mieux à vous
dire ça permettra aussi sur un master
class qui est vraiment très intéressant
de le faire sur deux jours par exemple
ça va également me permettre de
commencer une nouvelle série un nouveau
thème qui est j'ai lu en chou est la
lecture j'ai lu oui mais toujours
appliqué au mentaliste peut-être une ou
deux fois par mois dans les jours ou
semaines à venir il va y avoir d'autres
changements il va y avoir de la musique
dédiée par un créateur qui fait ça
vraiment de la musique on s'est
rencontrés plusieurs fois on se revoit
la très bientôt pour finaliser tout ça
il va y avoir également un nouveau logo
pour cette chaîne
alors là c'est pareil je travaille avec
un graphiste pour ça il est en train de
finir le logo j'espère qu'il vous plaira
je dis pas encore ce que c'est et je
travaille également avec un mec qui fait
du motion design et qui est en train de
créer une intro pour la chaîne sinon
trop très courte ça dure juste quelques
secondes mais ça permettait de mettre en
valeur le lot je ne sais pas exactement
quand est ce que ces trois choses vont
être mises en place puisque là forcément
je dépends de trois personnes
différentes mais je veux pas leur mettre
la pression je préfère que ce soit très
bien fait et en parlant de logo vous
serez peut-être amené de temps en temps
avoir ce logo là qui est le logo dont je
me sers pour mon nouveau spectacle tout
du moins la tournée de rodage vous le
savez cette année j'écris le nouveau
spectacle qui va être lancé en début
d'année prochaine en janvier 2010 est en
tournée de rodage dont la fiche est
d'ailleurs ici et je vais le rodez donc
en tournée durant une période de six
mois d'ailleurs il ya toutes les dates
qui vont arriver sur le site internet
vous avez le lien dans le descriptif
évidemment mais l'année prochaine tout
en faisant ces dates-là de spectacles en
tournée je vais continuer les vidéos sur
la chaîne je ne sais pas encore tous
mais je sais une chose c'est que je vais
par refaire une vidéo par jour pendant
un an
puisque ça c'était un défi si je
continue le défi n'a plus de sens en
fait en lui même donc je vais faire
moins de vidéo peut-être une deux par
semaine ce qui est sûr c'est qu'une fois
par mois il y aura une vidéo spéciale où
j'ai déjà le concept et j'ai déjà parlé
à des personnes pour travailler avec moi
qui sont ok donc ça ce serait un gros
format mensuel et puis peut-être une ou
deux par semaine sur des choses qui
ressemble plus à ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui mais qui j'espère sera
encore plus produite plus écrite et plus
créative et pour terminer les objectifs
vous savez qu'à cinquante mille abonnés
j'avais dit en début d'année que je
ferai un mental hop une rencontre un
espèce de mythe up où je testerai des
morceaux du nouveau spectacle avec vous
pour avoir votre avis ce sera dans
quinze mille abonnés du mois au moment
où je fais cette vidéo puisque là on est
à 35
quand j'ai lancé cette chaîne le 1er
janvier je m'étais ira si à la fin
d'année j'ai dit milou douze mille
abonnés sera pas mal ça fera mille
abonnés par mois sera super et j'ai eu
la grande surprise qu'on soit déjà 35
mille aujourd'hui c'est juste énorme
donc mon nouvel objectif au delà des 50
milles ce palier là pour faire le mental
up ensemble c'est d'atteindre les 100
mille abonnés j'ai un rêve secret je
vous le dis vraiment il me paraît
difficilement possible mais ce serait
tellement beau c'est qu'au 31 décembre
on est atteint les 100 mille abonnés et
de se dire que durant toute la durée du
défi on a été cent mille comme ça se
retrouver dans la team mental c'est un
vrai palier les 100000 et je me dis si
je les attends avant le 31 décembre dans
ces cas là je vais peut-être réfléchir
même différemment pour l'année prochaine
à quelque chose de très sérieux en fait
pour youtube pas très sérieux dans le
dans le fond mais dans la forme dans
l'organisation pour faire ben là pour me
consacrer en fait à mes vidéos youtube
voilà vous connaissez maintenant mon
défi ultime mon but ultime qui est
peut-être j'espère aussi votre but à
vous parce que une chose est sûre c'est
que c'est pas tout seul que ça avance
c'est vraiment grâce à vous depuis
départ j'en ai bien conscience et je
vous en remercie et si vous voulez
ensemble on peut essayer d'atteindre les
100 milles avant le 31 décembre
je voulais dit en début de vidéo je vais
aussi quelques surprises à vous a
annoncé pour les jours à venir les
semaines à venir les mois à venir dans
les surprises
il ya des mots comme poisson fécond que
j'ai eu la chance d'aller rencontrer à
grenoble on a fait une vidéo ensemble
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très très
très très bien merci beaucoup à lui il y
en avait également préparé quelque chose
avec max bird j'ai préparé aussi quelque
chose avec nos âmes
j'ai fait une vidéo sur la chaîne dès mi
mai que pro qui va sortir sur sa chaîne
à elle l'a par contre est très très
prochainement cdr demain je vous
présente une vidéo que j'ai fait avec
romain romain de la chaîne techno zone
test
elle sort demain cette vidéo allez un
petit peu longue parce qu'elle est
différente et de temps en temps il y
aura des vidéos différentes comme ça
c'est à dire que je vais alors
contre de romain je vais chez lui donc
la première partie de la vidéo est un
petit peu en mode blog et après on est
tous les deux sur le canapé c'est très
conversationnel comme ça on apprend
aussi des choses sur romain c'est un mec
excellent en fait il est juste très
drôle et très sympathique et ensuite
évidemment j'essaie de le mentaliser et
ça vous verrai ça demain si j'y arrive
pas voilà une vidéo différentes j'espère
avoir vos avis aussi dessus demain si ce
style là vous plaît j'en ferai plus
régulièrement
merci à vous d'être ici c'est la rentrée
vous allez déchiré je vais déchiré on va
déchirer en tout cas c'est ce que je
nous souhaite à nous tous les vacances
c'est fini tiens d'ailleurs dit moi dans
les commentaires vous étiez en vacances
j'aimerais bien voir ça se trouve on
était peut-être au même endroit des
moments on va voir ça vous me le mettez
dans les commentaires je lirai ça
n'oubliez pas de mettre un petit pouce
qui va mentaliser le ciel puisque il
pointera vers le haut à vous abonner à
la chaîne avant de partir si c'est pas
déjà fait et rendez vous demain à 17h
ciao